My opponent tonight
escaped from North Korea
when she was just 13 years old.
She's now
a human rights activist.
Yeonmi Park.
-Yeonmi, welcome.
-(cheering and applause)
Yeonmi, all right,
last week, President Trump
met with Kim Jong-un.
-Yes.
-How did you think that went?
And I'm assuming swimmingly.
That was unbelievable.
I cannot imagine
how can it go worse than that.
You thought it went...
you thought it would...
uh, poorly?
Yeah. I mean,
seriously, like,
how on earth did dic...
I mean, Kim Jong...
I mean, Kim Jong-un
was a guy that was praised by
the little... this free world.
The president of this United
States of America went there,
said, "It's an honor
to meet you."
Now, w...
you know, you got to...
you got to start with something
nice, and then, from there,
you give away promises about,
uh, where your army's
going to be.
Uh, those are, like,
the steps of diplomacy.
No. That's-that's...
In the name of diplomacy,
if that diplomacy ever worked,
I would not be here
as a defector.
I would not be
a human rights activist.
North Korea would not be
this way for 70 years.
So, talk to me a little bit
about that.
-You grew up in North Korea.
-Mm. Mm-hmm.
Uh, in-in looking
at, uh, this meeting
-between Donald Trump
and Kim Jong-un, -Mm.
were you optimistic at all?
Do you feel a meeting like that
could potentially bring about
peace?
Could that be the right step?
I initially thought
Trump was going to talk
about human rights issue.
He-he was right.
He said on the way to Singapore
in the press conference
that he was going
to bring everything in.
But the last minute, he said no.
He only just took lots of photos
with the dictator,
and he had a good time,
as he said.
And he just gave so much,
loved him as a dictator.
He praise him,
entire the summit,
and he just was so, like,
impressed by dictator
the whole time.
-And he didn't do anything.
-So you-you felt...
It's the legitimacy
that you had an issue with
in-in that meeting.
Yeah, I mean, everything.
The entire summit itself,
it was a reality show.
It was a show itself.
It was not politics.
That's what Trump gives ya.
He gives ya a good old show.
-Exactly. Yeah.
-What-what would you say?
What-what would you tell
Donald Trump?
What do you think
Donald Trump didn't know?
From your perspective,
walking into that meeting,
what's something you wish
you could have told Donald Trump
to know walking into a meeting
like that?
I think, for him,
that he does not really
understand there are people,
25 million people,
at this moment
that are waiting to be rescued,
to be saved by justice,
that people in North Korea
gonna get killed
if they don't sit up
when Kim Jong-un talks.
But that is not a something...
a subject
that Trump should praise for,
should be envy
to have in this country,
because he has no idea.
In North Korea, people
have no freedom of speech,
and I don't think
he really make that interview
-a full, like, reality.
-Yeah.
He's still catching up.
-I think they-they gave him
the books, -Right.
-but he's a slow reader. Um...
-Mm-hmm. (chuckles): Yeah.
Or he's, uh-- what's the word--
uh, not a reader.
-Yeah. -Uh, uh,
there are a lot of images,
a lot of pictures
that came from that meeting.
As somebody
who was in North Korea,
how do you expect
those pictures to be used?
Like, what are... what are
people in North Korea seeing?
How are they viewing
that summit?
I think, actually, I was
really surprised when the...
Trump showed that picture
to the-the sky.
That's what exactly I learned,
when Kim Il-sung,
our first dear leader died,
that it was raining.
The North Koreans said,
"Even the sky's crying
for the death
of our dear leader, the gods."
And that's what they say
in North Korea.
That I believed
the rest of the humanity
wanted to be like us.
That we had nothing to envy
because we had our dear leader.
And Trump proved that,
how much he loved Kim Jong-un,
how much he was impressed
by how tough,
that Kim Jong-un
killed his half brother
and how he just shot
his, like, uncle
then made it into dust.
And that's how exactly he prove
that all humanity wants to come
to under
the Kim Jong-un's leadership,
and I feel like we are
under Kim Jong-un's power now,
even being in America.
-You do feel that here.
Well, what... -Of course.
-Yeah?
-Yeah, now.
We are all under Kim Jong-un.
(Klepper stammers)
I mean, do you see
those connections, too?
Donald Trump and Kim Jong-un?
Does it feel
a pretty clear connection?
Do you...
W-What do you see there?
I mean, Trump is our president.
Believe it or not, he is.
(chuckles) He's the leader
of our country,
and he says he's going to make
North Korea,
the regime, as a normal country.
He's going to invite
this dictator
who's worse than Hitler, even,
and to going to make him
as a normal leader.
-Mm-hmm.
-Then what about us?
The dictator's not going to free
these people.
The dictator's killing us.
He's using starvation as a tool
to control the people.
What-what do people...
When you grew up in North Korea,
what's a day like
in North Korea?
Hating American bastards.
-Hating you.
-Oh!
That was my daily life.
So you're like a Democrat.
(laughter)
Yeah. Oh, my God. I guess so.
Yeah, entire day of my songs.
So it was like,
"I'm gonna build a tank
and kill American bastards."
-So like rap music.
-That was song that...
Yes, that was song that I sang.
So you-you are...
On a day-to-day basis,
that's the things
that you're being taught?
Those are the things
that you're literally singing?
Yeah, and the plays that I did
with my friends.
We were building a snowman,
and we put a big nose
because we heard
Americans have big nose.
And we put the green eyes
on top of it,
and we bring the hot water
and put on the snowman.
What happens? It melts up,
and we say, "Yay!
American bastards are gone."
That's a play we did.
-That's a hell of a Christmas.
-(laughs) Yeah.
Yeah.
And you left at 13.
-Yes.
-You mentioned that you, uh,
you saw an American movie,
and it made you realize
something was wrong
in your country.
-What was that movie?
-Titanic.
-You saw Titanic?
-Yeah.
And what did you get from that?
Think, of course,
Leo DiCaprio's handsome.
(laughter)
Oh, my forever love.
I think when I really watched
Titanic, I was so confused.
Why, first of all,
someone dying for love,
because we don't have word
for "love" in North Korea.
We only have word
for "dear leader."
Like, we only have to say
the word "love"
when we describe our feelings
to the dear leader.
And my mom never told me
she loved me.
And there's...
I couldn't believe why
someone made a movie
out of such a shameful story.
In North Korea, we don't know
who Shakespeare is.
The love stories,
the human stories
doesn't exist there.
It's only about how dear leader,
like, accomplished everything,
how he can do miracles,
and how he defeated
American bastards and freed us
and how he protects us today.
To be fair, most Americans don't
know who Shakespeare is, either.
(laughs) Okay.
But then you defected.
Tell me about defecting.
What was the straw
that breaks the camel's back?
It was hunger.
I was starving.
And it was not like
I-I had Internet,
and look up
on what to do with it.
It was...
I literally...
Luckily, I was living in the
northern part of North Korea,
and I could see the electricity
lights coming from China.
I mean, if you see the North
Korea on the satellite map,
it's the darkest place
on Earth.
We have the Earth Day
every day there.
-Good for the environment.
-(laughter)
But, you know,
that made me say like,
why China have electricity
at nights?
And I thought if I go there,
I might find something to eat.
And that's all I did
to find a bowl of rice.
We defected North Korea.
You defect, you're a refugee
looking for a place to live.
Yup.
-That is a situation America's
dealing with right now. -Mm-hmm.
As a refugee
who-who needed a home,
-who was fleeing
a North Korean regime... -Yeah.
...a hostile regime, uh,
what do you hope the country
you live in now can provide
for other refugees
who might be seeking, uh,
seeking some sort
of hospitality,
-or a hospitable environment?
-Right.
I think the...
When I went to South Korea,
uh, people ask me,
even in America,
"Where are you from?"
And I say, "North Korea."
They think, like, I say
I'm from North Carolina.
They usually don't connect the
North Korea to North Carolina.
And I say, "No, no,
I'm not from North Carolina.
I'm from North Korea."
And they say,
"What?! You're like me.
You look just like me."
I think
that's what we forget.
Refugees are just like us.
We are just so unfortunate
that we are born
in that country,
and we are being punished
for our birth place.
And no one should be punished
for their birth place.
It's not our crime
to be born in North Korea.
(applause)
Yeonmi, tell me something
I already know.
(sighs)
Oh, my God.
(Yeonmi laughs, Klepper laughs,
audience laughs)
Wow.
Or tell me something...
something I should know
that I don't.
That you should know?
Uh, I mean...
As-as a, uh...
as a dumb American.
As a dumb American. Right.
As I've heard
many people call me.
(laughter)
Who only knows what I see
on television about North Korea
and what I-I hear
from the Trump administration,
what is one thing to remember
about the, uh...
the experiences that
North Koreans are going through
day in and day out?
Freedom is not free.
Don't take it for granted.
You might lose it like us,
and gonna look
for a place to escape.
I thought, like,
when Trump praised Kim Jong-un,
and saying what a great leader
he is, like,
I'm like, "Where I'm gonna
escape to now?"
I'm in a country
where the dict...
president accept my dear leader
who was...
who is killing my people,
who is killing my relatives
right now
because I'm speaking out.
I'm still not a free person.
The Kim Jong's still trying
to kill me.
And that's why
freedom is not free.
We have to fight
for our freedom here
so we don't become
like North Korea one day,
and we have to sit up
when dictator speaks.
And that's what Trump wants--
that he wants us to...
to sit up when he talks.
Well, guys, author
of In Order to Live:
A North Korean Girl's Journey
to Freedom, Yeonmi Park.